[Musica]
grazie dell'invito e dell'introduzione
buongiorno a tutte ea tutti
per iniziare vi faccio vedere delle
immagini
[Musica]
ecco questi sono gli home movies
letteralmente film di causa film fatti
in casa film di famiglia
qual è la differenza tra queste immagini
e gli album di fotografie agli album di
famiglia le fotografie di famiglia ecco
la prima cosa che viene da dire che è il
movimento
il movimento e respiro il movimento è
vita
queste immagini sono
ricordi queste immagini prima di tutto
ci emozionano
che rapporto c'è tra il ricordo e
l'emozione l'etimologia della parola
ricordare ce lo dice direttamente
per i latini il cuore e luogo della
memoria
cordare
tornare al cuore quindi emozione ricordo
sono strettamente correlati e mantenere
la memoria registrarla c'è un termine
inglese molto vicino il verbo to record
registrare registrare i ricordi
questi ricordi registrati sono perduti
bisogna salvarli per fare questo è nato
un archivio a bologna circa 20 anni fa
che ha raccolto circa 30.000 pellicole
30.000 pellicole di famiglie italiane
film che abbiamo raccolto che
sono datati più antichi ormai circa 100
anni fa
quelle che avete visto sono immagini che
ho scelto nel formato nove e mezzo nove
e mezzo millimetro uno dei primi formati
diffuso tra il 1922 e il 1923 alcune
dell'immagine che avete visto sono degli
anni venti e pensate
una pellicola larga meno di un
centimetro veniva impressionata dentro
cineprese molto piccole e maneggevoli
cineprese avanzate sul piano tecnologico
per l'epoca che permettevano riprese
così ravvicinate come quelle che avete
visto ecco noi a bologna
nell'archivio movies siamo pieni di
queste immagini e lavoriamo su queste
immagini ma forse qualcuno si chiederà
come è venuta questa idea
potrei rispondere in tanti modi anche
con racconti lunghissimi ma di essere
una cosa che apparentemente non c'entra
nulla io sono storico di formazione mi
trovavo come laureando in un archivio ea
un certo punto mi trovo tra le mani una
cronaca scritta della peste del 1630
bologna ecco questa persona che aveva
lasciato questa testimonianza con le sue
paure come viverla viva la sua vita
quotidiana in quel periodo mi ha fatto
pensare
che anch'io avrei dovuto trovare la mia
cao capsula del tempo e l'ho trovata
effettivamente in queste immagini cioè
archiviare qualcosa che in futuro ci
permetta di guardare al passato
archiviare queste immagini significa
curarle curarli in che senso in tanti
modi
curarle perché sono oggetti delicati
pellicole che vanno maneggiate con cura
quindi sul piano proprio tecnico è
necessario sviluppare delle competenze
sperimentarle quello che abbiamo fatto
noi ma queste immagini queste bovine
significa anche come dire avere a che
fare con delle memorie private avere
attenzione per queste mar memorie
restituire un contesto attraverso la
raccolta delle testimonianze orali ad
esempio
catalogarle in modo accurato ed essendo
sempre consapevoli della loro
provenienza e curare queste immagini
significa anche interrogarsi su come
mostrarle oggi renderli contemporanea
voi avete visto una piccola selezione
già in questa forma sono estremamente
fruibili e ci dicono molto
un passaggio
della cura è la cosiddetta rimediazione
un termine tecnico passare da un medium
all'altro
dall'analogico al digitale dalla
pellicola al video e dal privato al
pubblico un termine tecnico però molto
importante su cui riflettere davvero è
un termine anche che con un doppio senso
potremmo dire che il digitale è il
rimedio all impossibilità di vedere
queste immagini
i proiettori e tecnologie obsolete che
non sapete che non funzionano più
il passaggio successivo è la
pubblicazione anche qui cosa significa
pubblicare queste immagini ad esempio in
rete
gli archivi come il nostro anno questo
obiettivo di rendere queste immagini
visibili di renderle parte di un
discorso pubblico
in questo caso si tratta di immagini che
nascono private quindi c'è questo
passaggio dal privato al pubblico che
altrettanto importante è altrettanto
delicato
parte di questo processo è anche la
proiezione e cosa intendo per proiezione
proiezione
significa per noi curatori anche mettere
in funzione i vecchi proiettori ricreare
quell'atmosfera quell'ambiente
trasmettere quella memoria anche in
senso didattico fare conoscere come
venivano utilizzate fruite le immagini
in passato ma significa ampliando lo
spettro
come dire proiettare anche noi
in un futuro attraverso immagini del
passato che sono la nostra eredità
culturale e che ci rendono più
consapevoli di noi stessi più pronti ad
affrontare anche le sfide contemporanee
ecco poi queste immagini sono testi
aperti sono quasi tutte mute queste
immagini
vengono
raccontate raccontate in vario modo
prima di tutto dai protagonisti coloro
che le hanno create in alcuni casi o
testimoni che hanno vissuto quelle
storie familiari ma anche più
genericamente tutti noi possiamo
raccontare a partire da queste immagini
perché tutti noi ci troviamo qualcosa
del nostro passato della nostra memoria
ecco queste immagini sono come le
madeleine
proustiane né assaggiamo una e si apre
veramente un mondo un mondo di racconti
e queste immagini ci permettono un
immersione
perché ce lo permettono perchè come
avete visto sono immagini estramente
dirette sulla realtà sono immagini
realizzate
con sguardi senza mediazioni su quello
che circonda e quello che circonda è il
mondo che si vive e il mondo degli
affetti e c'è anche questa restituzione
di sguardi e chi filma e chi è filmato
lo sguardo in camera
queste caratteristiche ci permettono di
immedesimarci e di entrare veramente
dentro quel mondo
ma come partecipare a questo archivo
ognuno di noi può farlo
ognuno di voi può farlo lo sa in
possesso di immagini dal prossimo
proprio passato familiare
il primo beneficio che otterrà sarà
quello di rivedere le immagini della
propria famiglia del proprio passato
poterle rivedere poterle commentare
poterne fruire
ma il vantaggio sarà un vantaggio
collettivo di tutti perché questo è un
archivio di tutti è aperto a tutti
e quindi chiudendo con il tema di questa
giornata
queste immagini
respirano ci fanno respirare ci
permettono nuove modalità di narrazione
della storia
per fortuna e anche grazie al nostro
lavoro queste immagini sono sempre più
visibili e sempre più al centro della
visione contemporanea le vediamo
incorporate nei film le vediamo nelle
installazioni le vediamo sempre di più
dei musei sono veramente un nuovo modo
di raccontare la storia
io vi ringrazio
e se volete approfondire il sito www.e
moving.it
[Applauso]